now one only person you can show
yourself around is me
oh I'm good now I'm good thanks
there's a war raging on our planet
if this criminal isn't found that war
may find its way sir anyone that can
help you or the family Oh
[Music]
they're calling an army
I've seen firsthand these things really
are
bumblebee there is only one way to end
this war you must protect earth and its
people
[Music]
this is how we stop down
you've cut me
I'm not going anywhere
hey everybody its charlie we got to
break down this new bumblebee trailer so
if you didn't see a whole bunch of
classic Gen 1 transformers Soundwave
shockwave we finally got Optimus Prime
when who's gonna be in the movies
somehow but not one of the biggest
characters because it's mostly supposed
to be a prequel all about bumblebees
character so I'll talk about plot in a
second we'll talk about the Gen 1
transformers first so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos this is coming out around
the same time that Aquaman is coming out
so they're a couple big movies coming
out in December this year but the big
things first it seems like what they're
showing us is is when bumblebee is on
planet earth with Hailee Steinfeld's
character who's also named Charlie named
like my name the Decepticons and the
Autobots back on Cybertron are still in
the middle of their final war it's the
fall of Cybertron effectively and you're
starting to see the beginnings of the
great migration of all them to Planet
Earth both Autobots and the Decepticons
so we get a much better look at classic
Cybertron than we've ever gotten in the
movies before so you have to think of
this is like a complete top-to-bottom
redesign of the way they visualized that
it looks so much better than the Michael
Bay redesigned that he did way back in
2006 with his first Transformers film I
think they were trying to make it edgy
put a whole bunch more sex in it but
that's not really what transformers is
about like hot chicks and short pants
it's mostly about the Autobots and the
Decepticons so I think that maybe when
they first launched the franchise they
were worried that people wouldn't be
down for that in live-action but the
special effects have gotten so much
better that it's a lot easier for them
to do the transformations and do really
cool classic versions that pop on screen
a lot more so everything is cranked way
up and it looks much closer to the
original cartoon than anything else that
we've seen before so it feels like this
visual style is the future of the
franchise like just set all the sequels
that they do for this movie or any other
spin-off movies set during the 80s so
they can keep these gen 1 designs people
will be like why didn't they just do
this to begin with we should have been
doing it this way the whole time you all
probably spotted some of the bigger
classic transformers and Decepticons we
finally get an
accurate version of Soundwave ravage is
the dog that jumps out of him and starts
running after the Autobots
this is shockwave and his seekers these
Decepticon jets that transform on
Cybertron those are just Cybertronian
jet that's all they're called they're
part of the Seekers we get classic
Optimus Prime both in the hologram et
phone home like the whole movie feels
like et the extra-terrestrial with
bumblebees character so there's that
funny twist on the idea of the
Decepticons phoning home they're trying
to call an army to earth you have to
stop them so this sort of gives you the
stakes of the film obviously the
Decepticons try to trick the military
John Cena sector 7 that's who these
people are into hunting down bumblebees
so that they can bring their Decepticon
army to earth so it's them sort of
playing both sides this fugitive could
bring our war to your planet better kill
him make sure to shoot on sight don't
ask him any questions
don't let him try to explain everything
just nuke him from orbit one bummer
though they did confirm that the
Decepticon that we thought was going to
be original Starscream is actually blitz
winged so because we see Optimus Prime
on Cybertron during that big war maybe
we'll see Starscream maybe we'll see
classic Megatron during that big fight
but they're not meant to be main
characters during the film these two
Decepticons they try to trick John
Cena's character into hunting down
bumblebee this is dropkick in shatter
shatters voice by angela bassett she's
the red one the blue one dropkick is
played by justin theroux barricade is
also supposed to be in the film - and
then obviously like I said during the
big Cybertron battle sequences anything
is fair game there could be just a whole
bunch of really tiny autobots and
decepticons that you guys know that are
in the background shots but some of the
trailer you've already seen before it's
Hailee Steinfeld's character on her 18th
birthday going to get a new car
obviously meant to mirror Sam Witwicky
during the first film like over the last
trailer they replayed that Bernie Mac
audio clip from the original movie I'm
sure there'll be a whole bunch more
Easter eggs for that first 2006
Transformers film even though I'm hoping
that this is going to be a soft reboot
of the franchise the dam seems like it's
going to be John Cena's sector 7 base
they're sort of like that paramilitary
organization much better shot of
Cybertron is it slowly getting ripped
apart so this is probably right at the
tail end of the Cybertronian Wars
you have to remember that by the time we
picked up in that 2006 Transformers film
it had already fallen so all the
Autobots had been making their way to
Planet Earth then over the course of the
franchise you would have stragglers sort
of come in like oh hey we've been in
outer space this whole time so we heard
the Autobots call to come back it's hard
to tell which character this is that's
leaving Cybertron it could be bumblebees
character it could be another character
but I love the way they cut it in that
misleading way when you see that
Decepticon fall from the sky and land
right on top of that car like implying
that it's going to turn into that car
another shot of the Golden Gate Bridge
just giving you an idea that this is
said in the San Francisco area if you've
been watching all the venom trailers
they all prominently Beach are shots of
the Golden Gate Bridge just because it's
really cinematic and it lets you know
exactly where it's taking place whole
bunch of chase scenes then obviously
they eventually get captured by John
Cena's sector 7 they start to take them
down you see this big fight here with
what looks like a giant antenna device
this might be what the Decepticons are
trying to use to call the rest of them
to Planet Earth then you get that funny
tag at the end where bumblebee is acting
like a cat or a dog trying to make it
through the door here just being all
cute this is like them going full et
wear et acts a little bit like a best
friend and a pet at the same time like
oh look at how cute they are but let me
know in the comments what do you
actually want them to do with the future
of the franchise I know everybody's
still waiting for a couple of really big
characters like we really want to see
classic Megatron turn into the gun we
want to see classic Starscream there's
still a lot of favorites out there so
what'll happen is is when we get closer
to the movie I'll do my non-spoilery
review like I would normally do
obviously venom is coming up in a couple
weeks so they'll be more footage for
that dropping suit there's a new
spider-man far from home video that I'm
working on so that should be up in a
little while but leave all your requests
in the comments below click here for an
official synopsis for the new black
widow phase 4 movie and click here for
that brand new venom trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you